anyone who watches her show knows we
often feature my assistant Sona
obsession there's a picture of her right
there yeah that was a little much
thought it down okay anyway about two
months ago I took Sona to Armenia where
we filmed a special episode of our show
where Sona reconnects with her Armenian
heritage yes says she's Armenian descent
and since then sone has become a bit of
a celebrity in the Armenian community
and on New Year's Day because she'd
taped this episode of our show she was
asked to ride on the discover Armenia
float in the Rose Parade and she did
check it out it was on TV or just
presentation it's remarkable
it includes more than 16,000 flowers
depicting famous on Sundays and
destinations and there's a probably more
Armenians in this part of the country
than there is anywhere else so yeah it
meets something when you're a star in
the our meeting yes it's a big deal yeah
now don't get me wrong I'm happy for
Sona and that was cool is a great
opportunity for her but as you know
she's still my assistant I've got kind
of worried that her newfound fame might
go to her head seriously and I want to
make sure that doesn't happen cuz I need
her to do the things she needs to do so
in fact Billy you there what's up Conan
Billy can you ask Sona to bring me a
half-caf vanilla latte with skim milk
and one Splenda please sure thing
all right why are you doing that now or
in the middle of the show I just want to
make sure Sona stays grounded and
remembers why she's here and what she's
supposed to do that's the point
[Music]
[Applause]
for me wait a minute Sona this is tea
just drink it
[Applause]
[Music]